the usually heaving heart of the capital
now symptomatic of this strange era
a return to work feels a long way off
even expensive real estate isn't immune
from covid19
thank you very much for having us five
and a half thousand people work in this
skyscraper
it's been lying almost empty for months
the landlords have installed
state-of-the-art cleaning
and contactless access for tenants we're
absolutely ready and prepared to welcome
our occupiers back and in fact we're
working with them on a daily basis
to ensure that the measures that we're
putting in place complement what they're
looking to do with their occupiers
but is it right that the onus is on you
well i think the onus is on all of us
to collaborate together to get the right
outcome and that's the government
the mayor of london ourselves and the
occupiers to work together and make sure
that we're
in a safe environment for everyone but
the landscape may have changed
if workers stay home what's the future
for the office
this is very different because we don't
know whether this is a blip
and actually the lights go back on
towards september october and everyone
returns to work or actually is this a
long term thing
that we have to react to when furlough
stops could there be
a similar reduction in head count which
could put a downward pressure on
space occupancy empty offices don't just
matter for those in real estate if
workers don't return
it has the potential to completely
redraw our towns and cities
because in the shadow of every
skyscraper in every commercial hub
there are thousands of businesses whole
economies in fact
that rely on the football they bring at
the foot of this building is a market
there's been one here since the 14th
century
rarely has it stood so still
malick's business is one of just a
handful still open but most of his
customers
are at home it's been really quiet
yeah we had businesses down 80 percent
since research back
wow and that what does that mean for you
guys eighty percent less it's that less
means
three people left the job the fear here
is that workers will never be back
some have already decided they won't
mike's consultancy was spending hundreds
of thousands on office space
he hasn't renewed his lease his 65 staff
will now work from home everybody's had
to move to a different way of working at
the same time
so any one company trying to do that on
their own would have found that really
hard to
to force that change but with everyone
doing it at the same time
everyone's got used to it and so it's
completely acceptable for us to be
working in this manner
going to work is as much about the
journey as the destination
commuters will need to feel safe unless
they do
lives and livelihoods will be changed
forever helen ann smith sky news